hello welcome to the lobby gamespot's
weekly hang out every tuesday at two
p.m. pacific right here on gamespot com
hi how many horse time you to our joint
is ever as ever pretty much now I sure
mr. Peter Brown and I good friend Alex
handy from the music the made the museum
of art and digital entertainment and an
Oakland California is here to join us
thank you very much Alex good to see you
again Danny a good to see you you guys
launched a Kickstarter today yes we did
it ten a.m. this morning and it's been
doing / it's been new pretty good yeah
we were up to about 2500 before we
started the show here of your $50,000
targus yeah as it were and this is
something that's I know near and dear to
Peter's heart it's game preservation is
near and dear to my heart after we went
out and talked to you a couple of months
ago and I think one of the most sort of
most shocking things to me nany when we
did I episode at a point was just how
few people there are actually preserving
what is like incredibly important things
for video game culture like going
forward absolutely when you came out to
talk to us we were talking about the
Copyright Office and the briefing we've
filed with the eff and I'm still in
shock that we were an institution that
had to comment on this because there's
nobody else out there who's doing this
there's archive.org there's a strong
Museum of play there's the digital games
museum down in Silicon Valley but
there's really not an institution you
know west of the Rockies that you can go
in and learn about games and play these
old games and understand them at least
not a permanent installation as it were
so what exactly is the made for people
who never heard of a google the maid is
a non-profit volunteer-run video game
museum we have free programming classes
for kids and adults in technology skills
ranging from scratch to see to unity to
pro tools and photoshop we also preserve
video game history through playable
exhibits along themes ranging from
platformer games the history of 3d women
in game development and we provide a
space for community events such as
tournaments and talks lectures all sorts
of things related to video games yeah
you do quite a lot i think when we went
out i was expecting to just see oh it's
like a museum of games it's just going
to be a bunch of glass cabinets with
stuff that i can't even touch or
interact with but what you do is like
there's a lot of hands-on education
happening but also people can go in and
actually
play games it's not like they're just
sitting there it's almost like a fruit
it's like a library absolutely it is
there is a huge library of over 5,000
games and you can play just about any of
them if you want to pc games are a
little tougher because you have to
install those console and older home
computer games we can fire up the vector
X is plugged in for example the NASA's
plugged in I can tell you that just
about every weekend you can find a
father and son or mother daughter or
mother son playing mario 3 or Street
Fighter 2 these games cross-generational
boundaries and people bond over things
like Pokemon so why do we need something
like the mate because the it's important
to preserve our cultural heritage I
think of it as being in 1920 and
somebody wants to start preserving film
this new medium of movies right in that
day and age people might have thought it
was frivolous or not so interesting to
preserve these things maybe they're not
art but today we obviously believe that
films are art we need to have
institutions that are built to preserve
and keep the cultural assets that are
generated along the way or else that
stuff is lost to history Peter I know
you collects a lot of games you go to
flea markets and you're very much like
knowledgeable in terms of like retro
like gaming history and then and
acquiring this the sort of stuff I think
I was probably of the mind like a lot of
people that like video games are
different to movies because they don't
come on reels or they don't come on
vinyl like video games are digital so
like surely they'll live forever right
but that's not the case right no
certainly not especially if you look at
any of the CD based games today those
products were not designed to last I
mean anywhere near forever you know a
couple decades at best when you have all
these different manufacturers employing
different methodologies for producing
these discs we're starting to see discs
fall apart but you know succumbing to
disc rot so over the years we're going
to lose this stuff and and it's kind of
a similar story to what you see with
games on servers companies can take them
off at any time and so we have these
these tangible products that are sort of
you know they don't have an opportunity
to stick around unless we protect them
so it's very important to do that and
museum is a really good way to do that
and and I also think that people backing
things up digitally is also very smart
because you know some people call it
piracy i call it preservation in some
cases because that's the only way we can
keep track of this stuff yeah it's
almost like but
when we talked back in May you said that
one of the biggest reasons we have
access to quite a lot of games is
because of the piracy market yeah it's
it's kind it's an absolute it's a shame
that the only reason we have the atari
st game catalog is because pirates
preserved that stuff game companies
didn't preserve it most of them were
acquired and closed down you know the a
lot of game companies go under very
quickly so all of these cultural relics
would have been lost if it wasn't for
sort of this crowd sourced effort to
preserve them now I'm not advocating
piracy but certainly there needs to be
an institution that can do this perhaps
us I'm the right now there is no legal
group like allowance for that it's it's
an interesting area of copyright law yes
and one of the things the reason we came
at you in the first place was when PT
got taken down like that was a very much
a situation where people like oh my god
digital things can be taken out of our
hands i remember in 2004 when half Lexie
was launched people were like oh buying
this digitally like what if I'll in the
future far-flung feature I won't be able
to play it or think about something like
World of Warcraft when like in 50 years
time if people want to go back and play
one of the most revolutionary MMOs of
all time like there's there may not be a
method of doing it in fact you guys have
a project for when the first ever MMO
that you're trying to resurrect uh yeah
the first graphical MMO for Commodore 64
in 1986 it was called habitat and
produced by lucasarts and we have the
source code for the server and the
client and we have undertaken a
year-long effort to bring the server
back it is ridiculously complicated so i
won't go into it but we are actually you
know moving along quite well we've we've
made more progress than i had ever
expected all the companies involved from
America Online to fujitsu to Lucas have
all been very very helpful in this and
they should be because we're preserving
their heritage their cultural assets
they made these things and if they want
them preserved you know they can work
with an institution like us to preserve
them so you guys are asking for fifty
thousand dollars at what what you need
that money for what is it going towards
so that is the absolute barest budget
that we could put together to move into
a new new space we have a number of
potential spaces which we're touring
this weekend we'll be updating the
Kickstarter with them but those funds
are going to be used basically to
renovate the space paint it make it you
know look nice like our current space
does now and would be used also to pay
some rent a few months worth of rent but
we're hoping to become sustain so
sustainable over time obviously we also
have to do a lot of fundraising through
donations from larger donors as well
yeah and the spacer in now it's it's you
I think it's fair to say you've done
well with what where you are is an old
building like when we went in to talk to
you a roof of collapsed and one of the
janitors had broken their leg yeah
accident like yeah I'm where your
classroom was actually yeah the ceiling
collapsed in our classroom because the
building is a hundred years old and it
was the original ceiling so the ceiling
was made out of cast iron and just
collapsed Wow yeah heavy yeah nobody was
hurt but it's definitely a sign we
needed to get out of the building we
needed to get out anyway because it you
have to buzz in and go up the stairs
we're not a retail space right now but
considering we get you know 40 50 60
kids a weekend for smash tournaments
we've done pretty good considering how
hard it is to find us people would say
that like why do you need to be
somewhere that's like visible but I
guess the point of a museum is that you
are easily it's easy to get there and
it's easy to find us right yeah it's a
it needs to be a retail location I don't
think that the sfmoma would work if you
had to go anyway close in and sign in at
a desk or anything like that you know we
sort of visit viewed the original space
that were in now as a lab because the
video games museum was not a thing when
we started and over the four years we've
really discovered what it is that that
people want they want Mario 3 they want
to play Street Fighter they want to see
games that maybe they heard about as a
kid but didn't get a chance to play and
they want to share these games with
their family and friends I think one of
the things that kind of struck me when
we talked last time was that you had a
you did fund rise to about 20 thousand
dollars years ago and you actually made
that stretch for far more than you would
originally intended yeah that basically
lasted a year and it I don't know how we
did it I still don't know how he did it
but we did you know we use tables off of
the street corners TVs people would put
out on the curb we would grab them and
use them we really really scrape every
quarter to get every cent out of it we
but it's all thanks to our wonderful
volunteers I mean they were the ones who
helped put this Kickstarter together
into the videos and everything we have a
very good dedicated group of volunteers
we always need more mmm so if people are
looking for it on Kickstarter would they
just search for the made right now uh
yeah where you can go to our website the
maid org th e ma de org and there's a
link right at the top there's also our
Twitter our Facebook I believe you guys
are going to have a link to yeah we're
good we've got a couple of news stories
I was tweeting about
this morning as well because it is
something that's like I definitely was
very sort of ignorant they saw like my
catalog of games is the the Commodore
Amiga and like you said most of them are
pirate games that I had copies of that
turned up in some games which never made
it to Ireland room and never made it to
Europe and now I have them like like I
cherish them and not only because I know
that I won't be able to play them in the
future if I lose them again but I guess
thinking more further ahead that other
people will never be able to play
sensible world of soccer if I don't hold
on to this cartridge perhaps and Peter
you've obviously have a lot of games
which are very rare you've all consoles
as well is there any like games and
consoles that you sort of have been
searching for it I just suspiciously
difficult to find or games that have
kind of disappeared into the ether of
time that you wouldn't think of sure I
mean I think a good example is if you
look at sort of the the end of a life
cycle for a console companies publish
fewer copies of games and they would
like when it's really popular and people
are really ingrained in new content so
there's a lot of stuff on older japanese
systems like companies like sunsoft
would publish very like limited runs of
their games and stuff like that is
really hard to come by now but I
actually this brings me to a question I
wanted to pose to you because I come in
this intersection of preservation and
game collecting game collecting is on
the rise right now as both a profitable
market and as a trend like for a hobby
that people are undertaking do you think
that people are perhaps missing the the
real reason to get this stuff because I
know a lot of circles when it comes to
game collecting good were like oh I have
the valuable game like you couldn't find
that I got it there's competition and I
feel like there should be more
cooperation in this regard and I hate I
hate that some stuff is sort of only
reserved for the people who are rich
enough to get it mmm when they should
really be contributing to something like
made and i know i have stuff I'd
actually like to give you guys so I'd
love to you guys to my first question
and know how I and other people can
donate as one well first off on the
donation front we can give you a tax
write-off for any donations and we
accept things in person and through the
mail we had a guy in Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania send us over 400 Saturn
games oh man nice well he would buy lots
on ebay and give us everything you
didn't want so we have like an the
entire Saturn catalogue of like dating
Sims yeah
but when it comes to collection you know
we're not gonna say anything to stop
people from collecting I just like comic
books people love it and that's fine
there's totally room for that it saves a
lot of stuff from going in the dumpster
but what I don't want to see is if
there's one copy and somebody's got it
like the Charlie Brown game on Atari and
you know what the Charlie Brown game on
Atari 2600 game no but he's ever played
it cuz one guy has it and he won't let
anybody plate he when he won't know it
dumped the wrong sir and that's that's
where the community needs to work if
there's something that there's one of
right we need to dump it and make it
because it's digital we can copy it and
pass it around and and preserve it but
they know if somebody wants to go out
and get that box copy of Zelda or legend
of zelda you know that's fine that's for
sure it's fun to collect that stuff you
know you and I love flea markets half
the fun is finding the stuff it is it's
true but you know it's at the same time
I feel like there are some things that I
have that I don't have the time to play
that I wonder like is this best serve
here or should this be in the hands of
somebody who can actually take care of
it and then appreciate it in the
meantime oh it's something I struggle
with because I obviously like these
things but I like them because like you
say they're pieces of our heritage that
I get to hold on to but I wish they
could be preserved in a perfect way like
note standards and we need a real place
to do that you gotta will perfect Alex's
name on of course if you're a fan of
video games you know this is obviously
we like to think that this stuff is
getting done obviously it's not getting
done if you guys are having to reach out
and look for money it's not like it's an
easy thing to do so people can go to the
Kickstarter for the made 2 point 0
donation if you have like a couple of
bucks to do it by all means your backer
rewards started five dollars right now
yeah but you know lots of people
donating it one dollar yeah I'm we're
putting all names on the website under
donors no matter how much money you give
and right now are you guys still in your
current Oakland office is it available
you guys open this weekend we have a big
party on the twenty-sixth from noon to
six everybody's invited it's our fourth
anniversary party it's a fantasy RPG
themed parties or come in costume
excellence hetalia thank you for coming
in thanks for having very much for all
the work you do as well it's obviously
doing a great service for the video
games community and we wish you all the
best of success with your Kickstarter we
wouldn't be able to do it without your
viewers no worries yeah so get on over
there I will stick the and
link in the O's are right there or look
at it right there beautiful Josh saw
making it happen the maid org head there
or go to add the maid on twitter and
contribution to our collective video
game history
you